لماذا أدعو إلى وقف إطلاق النار في غزة أنا
صحفي لون لماذا أدعو إلى
وقف إطلاق النار في غزة أنت 46 4600 طفل
قتلوا 46 أعرف أنها سيارة هادئة
وأعتذر عن الإساءة أفهم ولكن
الأطفال يموتون الأطفال يموتون يا
سيدي أكثر  أكثر من 40 عامًا عندما أدعو إلى CE، يتم
قتلهم بأسلحتنا،
الأسلحة الأمريكية تقتل الأطفال في غزة، من
أنت، اسمي آرون ماتاتي، أنا
صحفي، تشرفت بلقائك، آرون
بالمثل، من فضلك توقف عن التحدث معي، أنا
آسف يا سيدي، إنه أمر رهيب. الواردات أكثر من
11000 مدني هي العمل والحديث عن
القتل. أنا صحفي في
المنطقة الرمادية، ما هي المنطقة الرمادية،
إنها موقع إخباري مقره الولايات المتحدة، جيد
لك، شكرًا لك والآن
مع موقعنا  أدعم الأطفال الذين يُقتلون،
أنا آسف لأنني أسلحتنا، أطلب
منك توضيح لماذا لا تدعو إلى وقف
إطلاق النار، أنت تزعجني وتزعج
كل من حولي من الأطفال والرجال الذين
يُذبحون، أنا أطلب منك،
يرجى توضيح السبب  لا تطالب
بوقف إطلاق النار، توقف يا سيدي، هل يمكنني الحصول على
بعض المساعدة
هنا، الأطفال يُقتلون
بأسلحتنا، أطلب منك التوقف لماذا لا
تتوقف، لماذا لا تطالب بإيقافك عن
مقابلتي، أنت تزعج
الجميع من حولك، إنها أزمة  الآن كيف
حصلت على هذا المقعد لقد اشتريت المقعد،
لا، إنه يزعجني وحكومتنا
تدفع ثمن الأسلحة التي تقتل
الأطفال والرجال، أنا أسأله لماذا
أدعو إلى وقف إطلاق النار، هل يمكنك توضيح
ذلك من فضلك، هل يمكنني أن أسألك؟  لشرح سبب
دعوتي، لقد سألني بالفعل خمس مرات،
لن أدعو إلى إطلاق النار، فأنا أؤيد بقوة
الموقف الإنساني، وقد حثثت
الحكومة الإسرائيلية على استهداف
حملتها ضد تاماس، لكن عليك أن
تعتقد أن الحملة تستهدف القوات الجوية الخاصة (
SAS) عندما يكون المدنيون  يتم ذبحهم
بينما يموت الأطفال والحاضنات
بسبب انقطاع الوقود، سأقوم
بإلقائك من هذا القطار، من فضلك
توقف عن القيام بذلك، يجب أن أطرح هذه
الأسئلة 10 مرات، وستحصل على
إجابة مناسبة وقياسية بشكل احترافي  أخرج مني قدر المستطاع، هذه ليست
صحافة محترفة، من فضلك انهض
واغادر الآن، لا أعتقد أنه من الإنساني
أن نذبح الأطفال، هذه هي المشكلة
هنا، أدرك أنني لا أفعل ذلك، كما
أنني أحشد الأطفال أيضًا.  سيناتور،
سيارة هادئة، أنت تنتهك
القواعد الأساسية لكيفية عملنا على amtr، حسنًا والسؤال
هو St وأعتقد أننا
نخرق القانون الدولي من خلال دعم
Mass، نعم لقد أمضيت الكثير من وقتي،
يرجى توضيح
السبب  لا تدعو على الأقل إلى وقف
فلوريدا